Uh, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p.
This is, I was hoping that nobody would notice
this, but I am increasingly getting more and
more questions about a video in which I appear
getting a massage.
Take a listen to this for real.
They go listen to this.
Hey David.
I saw a very, uh, disturbing picture of what
appears to be you laying on a massage table
within the Seuss, uh, sticking her hand under
the towel.
Uh, I thought on the Youtube channel of the
progressive voice.
I was curious if you could let us know what
that is.
Thank you.
A big fan of the show.
Yes, of course.
Yeah.
Listen, so once again, people have been trolling
the youtube archives.
I used to when I was like 21, 22 maybe I had
a video production business.
We produced a lot of instructional videos
from everything from jewelry making to dog
training to massage therapy.
And on a very interesting day back in who
knows what year, uh, we did a massage therapy
video series for, I believe it was for [inaudible]
expert village and a um, a misuse customer
aim, a massage customer was necessary and
I played that a customer, so I'm not going
to link to this.
If people are really curious, they can look
around and find it, but I can assure you it
was all on the up and up.
Okay.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We'll talk about Eric Swalwell ending his
presidential campaign.
Obviously that makes sense.
And many people should do the same thing.
Uh, there's this really weird series of people
who are licking ice cream.
They're opening up ice cream in, in grocery
stores and licking it and closing it and putting
it away.
And one of them has been arrested.
And we'll also talk about the economic impact
of a $15 minimum wage nationally based on
a new congressional Congressional Budget Office
report.
Really interesting data.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, David pacman.com/membership to become
a member patriotic
homme slash David Pakman show to become a
patron.
Both.
We'll give you instant access to the bone